Hi everyone it's Jerry. This is round 10 from
the 2013 World Chess Championship match between
Anand and Carlsen. Going into this round Carlsen
has a 6 to 3 lead over Anand. And Carlsen
with the white pieces in this one opened with
e4. And for the first time in the match we
get to see the Sicilian Defense. Keep in mind
Carlsen needs only a draw or a win in order
to become World Champion. It is a race again
to 6 and a half points. And we see the Rossolimo.
Knight blocks and as a follow-up, d4. If you're
looking for a fairly quiet system in reply
to the Sicilian, bishop b5 line might be something
to look into. Carlsen at this stage in the
match not wanting to complicate the position
too much. So we have this exchange, and soon
as the bishop is questioned, white gives it
up. But has at least inserted c4 so that there's
going to be control over the two potential
pawn breaks--d5 and b5. And we'll see a lot
of emphasis placed on controlling these squares
from here on out. So first knight f6, bishop
g5. You may not think there's too much difference
between these two moves at this moment but
there certainly is. By keeping pressure on
the knight, there's not time to fianchetto
the bishop successfully because you can take
the knight off, damage the structure, and
this knight would be granted a beautiful home
on d5. But if you were to bring your knight
out, well now there's time for black to maybe
consider this. But it's bishop g5, and so
the bishop has to go elsewhere. Knight c3,
bishop e7, castles. Bishop c6 putting pressure
on e4 and this is a quite common maneuver
out of this variation to drop the queen back.
There's a few reasons behind that. One it
vacates the d4 square for the knight. It could
grab the bishop, and it's still keeping a
close eye on the two potential pawn breaks--d5
and b5. Black castles, sure enough the knight
posts in the center, reinforces the structure
with b3. And now we grab that bishop. And
we play our rook to c1. This might be tempting
as well. It's a half-open file, but it doesn't
address this potential pawn break. If rook
on f to d1, we have b5 and you can't take
cause you would drop the knight. So we need
to first secure our knight position so b5
is no longer a good idea. You could just win
a pawn. Maybe there's even something sneakier.
So we don't do that. b5 is not allowed. Bishop
has a question thrown to it. This is also
a flight square. Knight to d7. There's two
possibilities for this knight now. b6 isn't
really doing anything but tying down the queen
to its defense. Better post for the bishop.
Hard square to argue with. It's very well
centralized and pointing right at g7. There
could maybe one day be another piece converging
on that g7 point. So finally the last rook
gets involved for black. A little flight square
for white, and this queen is retreating to
only take up a better post. She eventually
wants to rake the 5th rank. All of the white
rooks are working for white now. And with
queen to d2 there is this common knight pivot
that is available, exploiting the queen's
unprotected nature. Notice how if b5, there
could be knight d5. There's no time to take
the knight. The queens are in tension. Queen
on a5 is unprotected. If you take the queen,
you don't take back right away. You take the
piece with check. And only then take the
queen back. And then white is doing quite
well reinforcing c4. The one thing you really
don't want to happen structure-wise on the
queenside for white is this sort of thing
where they're split. But clearly in this variation
the rooks are well positioned to keep the
structure as is--an a-b structure. So we don't
have that. But that is the idea that is in
mind after queen d2. And the king gets out
of it. King to f8, so that knight d5 isn't
available. Queen takes queen. Well you can't
take a piece now with check. The king is on
f8. So king f8 it is. Queen to b2, and there
might be some issue on this g7 square. Well
the king comes back. And during the live stream
I had thought that maybe we would have some
repetition. The queen going back and forth,
the king going back and forth. But certainly
Anand is looking for more. It may seem like
this is appealing to take that pawn and then
land a discovered check, but it's just not
working out. Black at the end of it is up
a piece. So what did we have? We had a4, clamping
down on this b5 advance. Queen to h5, knight
to e2. Two possibilities for the knight to
maybe harass the black queen. Bishop f6, and
now at this point now that the bishops are
in tension with one another. As soon as he's
no longer around to watch over d6. Well you're
going to have a lot of pressure being placed
on that point. He's a number one defender
of the d6 pawn. So he is challenged right
away. He's recaptured as otherwise you would
be dropping the rook. You need to take with
the rook, and after queen to e5 the idea will
be to eventually question the queen's position.
First piling up on d6. Knight f6 is there.
There's pressure now on e4. That is defended,
and there is also no thought of d5. The queen
would be hit. And so what gets played after
rook e3, we have rook d7. And now a very clamping
down type of move, a5. You could forget about
playing b5. The queen is there to support
keep in mind. And now we have after queen
g5 an evaluation shift. What's maybe better,
and this is a computer recommendation is g5,
to secure this queen position. But instead
in the game, after a5, it was queen g5 which
now allows e5, breaking open the position.
Hitting at these two points. The knight has
to run in reverse in order to defend d6. Now
in the game we had pawn takes pawn, but what
was available was also knight g3, or maybe
even knight c3 with ideas of hitting the queen
and then also converging on d6. However what
was chosen is the immediate capture. And this
pawn needs to be tracked down right away.
If something like b4-c5 is allowed and that
pawn is defended, with that sort of structure,
well it's going to be game over for black.
So it's rook c6. f4 first, and we're going
down a line now where we're going to have
all major exchanged, and we're going to enter
a knight, king and pawn endgame alone. So
f4 is first inserted. The queen needs to drop
back to corral the pawn on d6. And we have
everything trained on this point, and sure
enough all major pieces coming off the board.
And it was important by the way in all of
those cases that the knight would be the last
one to capture as otherwise there are moments
where c5 could be played, exploiting the pin
on the d-file. So that's why we have that
exact order coming about. And the knight being
the last one to recapture. And now in this
endgame, the idea is to get the king more
active. And very active is this white king
with these next moves, making a b-line right
for the b-pawn. Black is there however, just
in the nick of time to stop white from putting
pressure on b7. So what follows is getting
the knight to a better post. An even post
on e4, looking at the d6 square, hitting at
f7. Also looking for some fork. Maybe picking
up the g-pawn. Knight e3, g3. A question is
thrown to the knight. He does run into d6.
And after g5, we give a check, and another
check. And now this where there was a big
think for Carlsen having about 61 minutes
remaining on this clock. He invested a good
chunk of that--nearly a half hour spent on
knight g8. And you may wonder why so much
time was invested on such a move. Well look
at the variation that comes about where after
takes, takes, king g7. The knight--he is trapped.
White is giving up the knight in exchange
for tracking down these pawns, and then having
a foot race. Literally a foot solider race
to see who can queen first. So he doesn't
just want to give himself up. He needs to
take somebody down with him. He grabs a pawn
at least on f5, and then the king hunts down
the b-pawn. Whereas the knight tracks down
the f-pawn. And before you know it we have
two passed pawns. King b6 is there clearing
the way for the pawn, and also shouldering
off the knight. It's a big race, and at the
end of it we have both sides queening. White
queen's first, and then takes up a nice residence
in the center. Even without these pawns on
the board, it's still a very difficult win
for black. Queen and knight versus queen should
be a theoretical draw but we have the game
actually ending much more abruptly. Keep in
mind that you can't, at this point, take the
pawn. She has to watch over the knight. So
what is tried is a knight check, king b5.
Knight takes on b3. The queen now is able
to give a check, and at this moment I was
able to notice that the game would be ending
very soon. Because by force it would either
be a perpetual check or the queens would be
exchanged. And that right there would secure
a draw. So what was played is king to h6.
And what was the follow up? Queen b6, forcing
a queen exchange. What else would there have
been to do? Going to one of these squares...well
the queen basically keeps making use of these
three squares. Wherever the king goes, you
continually give a check until he has to go.
Well it's either perpetual check or he ends
up somewhere on this 6th rank. So what was
played is queen c7, king h6, queen b6, and
the queens are exchanged. And with that, well
the game finishes up like this, with the pawns
being captured. And at this moment right here
we go all the way down to move 65, knight
takes pawn. And it is at this point it is
of course a draw. No side can win, and with
that the World Chess Championship title goes
to Magnus Carlsen. So congratulations to him.
I've covered all games now. It feels good
to be done, and I hope you enjoyed tuning
for this. Maybe this is the first video you're
watching, but I covered all of these games.
All ten games of this match. And at the end
of this video, I'll include a playlist so
you can check them out if you missed any of
them. So thank you for tuning in. Thank you
for your support as well. And I hope you enjoyed
this World Chess Championship match, and again
congratulations to Magnus Carlsen. That's
all for this video. Take care, bye.